this is fun too the tip and tails
welcome
of jersey shore star vinnie g over the
weekend as the celebrity guest host for
a third residency here's what vinnie had
to say about putting on that bow tie for
another round well the best part about
doing this show is that like it's a
family and everyone i knew here it was
there was no weirdness it was just like
welcome back like we're doing this again
and now all the new guys are cool too
and i'm sure i'm gonna have the same
experience with them
vinny really put it all out there on the
stage friday night uh jc you just said
where's the shirt yeah where's your
shirt uh no shirts allowed of course
it's super nails it was a lot of fun and
also as we mentioned vinnie rose to fame
on the mtv hit show jersey shore
so when i had the chance to talk with
him last week i put his knowledge to the
test to see what he remembers from back
in the day okay all right check it out
let's see what we got i looked up some
some quotes from the og jersey shore
days and i want you to guess who said
them okay cool and i had to flush
through some of them to find the not r
rated one so
we'll put you on the spot here and see
how you do okay
all right i feel like this first one is
pretty easy but okay here we go who said
there's no way i'm going to jersey
without my hair gel can't leave without
my gel
that's definitely paulie d
yes okay we're starting out easy next
step
yes
my only rule never fall in love at the
jersey shore
ronnie okay good job you're two for two
okay
who said this quote everybody loves me
babies dogs you know hot girls cougars i
just have unbelievable math appeal
that would be mike the situation wow
all right three for three okay next up
you never really see me acting a fool on
tv okay so that's me um but i'm gonna i
just cheated because um
someone brought that up recently to me
and i'm like i said that so uh that's
the only reason why i do that right now
well i will say that's one of the only
appropriate quotes that i could yeah so
that's why someone else probably felt no
it's funny i say that i would never act
a fool yet all the other quotes of me
were me acting a fool that you can't
stay so uh i kind of was lying during
that